as any python programmer hopefully knows
a list uses memory
sys.getsizeof will tell us how many
bytes python thinks this object takes
this list takes 120 bytes
generally speaking a bigger list will
take more memory than a smaller one but
did you know that two equal lists can
actually take up different amounts of
memory
both of these lists contain just three
zeros and they compare equal
in fact the sizes of the lists are not
at all what determines how much memory
they take
here i have an eight element list taking
up the same 120 bytes that the three
element list takes up
and the seven element list takes up even
less space than the three element list
and it just keeps going all three of
these lists contain three zeros they're
all equal to each other and they all
take different amounts of memory so what
on earth is going on here how could this
list take 50 percent more memory than
this list when they contain identical
elements and compare equal
okay let's investigate maybe there's
some kind of caching going on where the
first list to be created somehow just
takes more memory
nope that's not it if we reorder them
their sizes remain the same does
anything change if i use variables
instead of literals
nope same answers was there something
special about a length of 3 well we get
different sizes because this is a bigger
list but they're still all different
answers
what if i extract the common element out
into a variable
interestingly this actually does change
the answer for the first list
using literal zeros gave 120 but using a
variable e gave 80. what about the size
of the object this number is much larger
and will take more memory than zero
but we don't see any increase in the
size of the list what if i use a really
big object
clearly the size of this element e does
not play a role in whatever getsizeof is
returning
what if after the lists are created we
change their contents
nope still the same numbers as in the
original example
what if we add more elements
now we're getting somewhere two of the
lists became the same size
and if we add a bunch of elements then
they all become equal
and if we shrink them all back down to
three elements then they remain all
equal in size
but if we start them at 1000 and see
8056
and then shrink them just a little bit
we still see 8056.
it's almost like the lists remember
what's happened to them before
but then if you change them enough then
they forget
okay enough anthropomorphizing lists
what's actually going on here in order
to understand what's going on we really
have to understand what get size of is
actually returning to us what getsize of
returns is supposed to be the size of
the object in bytes as it would be
represented in memory on your computer
and as we already saw getsizeof only
counts the size of the object itself not
any sub-objects so to understand what
getsizeof is actually returning to us we
need to understand what list actually
looks like under the hood let's build up
what the internal structure of a list
looks like
first we have the object reference count
and a pointer to the object's type
under the hood every object in python
starts with these two fields
a list is also a variable sized object
so it contains an object size field this
contains the length of the list
then we have two list specific fields
this ob item points to the contiguous
memory where all the actual data for the
list is stored the final field is
allocated
it's an integer telling us how many
elements could fit into the memory that
ob item points to
so notice ob size tells us how many
elements are in the memory
and allocated tells us how many elements
could fit in the memory
and this distinction is the key to
understanding what get size of returns
the value that get size of returns is
based off of this allocated number
not the length of the list
if you think about it whether you put
python objects in this memory or not
once it's allocated you're using it so
that something that gets size of should
be counting and the last piece of the
puzzle is that for garbage collection
purposes python stores two pointers just
before the object starts under the hood
this is what a python list's internal
structure looks like
here's how we actually calculate the
value the getsizeof returns first is the
static part of the list each of these
fields takes up probably eight bytes on
your machine
if we ask for the size of an empty list
we see that it's 56
that corresponds to seven fields times
eight bytes apiece is 56 bytes
for the variable part of the list python
stores a pointer to each of the objects
in the list so the variable size is just
the size of a pointer which is another
eight bytes times the number of slots
for those pointers that have been
allocated
and again in this calculation it's using
allocated which is the number of
elements that could fit in the memory
not ob size which contains the actual
number of elements that are stored in
the list
to better understand what's going on
let's solve for the allocated variable
and then examine it
in most programming languages this would
be referred to as the capacity of the
list
it's how many total elements could fit
into this list before i need to get more
memory
let's start with the empty list
the capacity of the empty list is zero
meaning when you make an empty list
python has not allocated any extra space
for the list if you want to start adding
elements in it will first need to
allocate memory
now let's try repeatedly appending
elements to x and seeing how the
capacity changes
after we first add an element in the
capacity jumps up to 4 then it remains
at 4 until we hit that capacity then the
capacity jumps to 8 and remains until we
hit 8 then 16 and remains until we hit
16
so it looks like it's always a multiple
of four
and so far it's been doubling but once
we get to 16 then it jumps up to 24. so
it stops doubling every time
then from 24 jumps to 32
and from 32 it jumps to 40 and 40 to 52
then to 64
76
92 and 108. basically what's happening
here is whenever we hit a capacity limit
python must allocate more memory and
then it has to copy all of the old data
into the new memory
copying can be expensive and more
expensive the longer the list is
that's why there's a difference between
the capacity and the length at all
if you're running a business and you're
renting out space for your employees to
work in say your current building could
fit 20 employees well your business is
expanding and you're looking to hire
your 21st employee are you going to go
out and find a building that can fit 21
people
no you're expecting to continue growing
and it would be a complete waste to get
a building with 21 people and then have
to get a whole new building for your
22nd employee instead you'll probably
rent a room for maybe 30 employees or 40
employees you don't want to go crazy and
rent a room for a thousand employees but
a fixed percentage bigger than your
current capacity is something that makes
sense we're doing the exact same thing
here with the memory in the list
this kind of proportional or geometric
resizing is something that you see in
almost every programming language it's
used in python's list c buses vector and
java's arraylist it turns out that
python resizing uses a factor of
approximately 9 8. we can check this by
repeatedly appending to a list and
seeing when the capacity changes and
then looking at the ratios the ratio
starts out larger but very quickly
approaches 1.125 or 9 8.
does anyone remember what the original
question was at this point
yeah that was quite the deep dive but
let's get back to it
why does getsizeof return different
sizes for all of these lists
well now that we know that getsizeof is
just a shifted scaled version of the
capacity let's take a look at the
capacities instead when a list is
constructed what determines the capacity
that python chooses
well every different way of constructing
a list is a different function and it
could choose whatever capacity it wants
in this case it knows there's going to
be exactly three elements so it chooses
a capacity of three okay that makes
sense
if you think about how a list
comprehension might work it's akin to
just repeatedly appending elements
and indeed four is the capacity that you
would get if you started with the empty
list and then repeatedly appended
elements when you add the first element
the capacity jumps up to four and then
it stays there because we only added
three elements so the only really weird
one is this why did this get a capacity
of eight
and remember it's even weirder because
if we used a variable e instead of the
literal zero then we get a capacity of
three
again makes sense because we just have a
literal with 3 elements so the capacity
of 8 in this case is just a quirk of
using literal zeros again it's a
different function called to construct
the list so they can just choose
whatever capacity they want
if we subsequently add a thousand
elements into each of them then they all
end up with the same capacity of a
thousand if we then drop them down to
500 elements they still have that same
capacity
the length of the list changed but its
capacity didn't but if we drop to 499
one less than half the size then python
adjusts and actually shrinks its
capacity
i guess they decided no need to waste as
much space if you're using less than
half of what you were
so reality check it's really good to
understand the internals of a language
if you're really trying to master it
but in practice is knowing these
capacity things going to help you in
your daily programming life
probably not especially since you can't
change the capacity algorithms
at best knowing the internals of how
capacities work in python will save you
a factor of two times memory
but let's be honest in python you're
rarely ever concerned with how much
memory you're using
so good to know good to understand the
internals but not necessarily something
that you need to think about as always
thank you to my patrons and donors for
supporting me
if you enjoyed the video please consider
becoming a patron on patreon
and of course don't forget to like
comment and subscribe see you next time